I've been using the right sense on January 2020. The left kidney tumor has been growing slowly from 2.5 to 5 centimeters now.
It seems this protocol is not effective. Let me stop right there. Well, no, I know everybody wants their, you know, their cancer to disappear and go away. That's why you're trying to do what you're doing, right?
So, I don't, I don't know the whole mode of this saccomic, but you have to remember I mean, if maybe if you were doing what you, what you're currently doing, your tumor could be and been completely invasive and taking over your whole body and that's not 5 centimeters, it's 10 centimeters now.
You just don't know. So, don't discount all the positive things that you've been doing all the positive energy that you put into healing your cancer and doing, you know, everything you're doing, whether you're doing standards of care with your ecologist or you're doing alternative things with me or somebody else, don't discount what you're doing.
But, you know, it's not working because my tumor doubled in size. Well, maybe it would have quadrupled in size. That means said, okay, what do I do now? Well, that's the question of the day.
You could try some different protocols. You could try some different things. I know this person has tried a lot of different things. It is doing a lot of things currently.
You have to think about using some standards of care. So, I know this person is because they're answering their question right here is surgery possible.
I think, yeah, you do need to talk to a surgeon and get some opinions again with everything you want to pray about it. Make sure you feel a lot of peace about that about the decision.
And sometimes people will go, why you still know I just don't know. Well, go slower than make the decision. You don't have to make the decision tomorrow. Go slow. Talk to some surgeons. Meet with them. Schedule some appointments.
Let God open up the door for you. And you feel that it's the right thing to do when it gets to that point. But sometimes we got a step to the river before he parks the water.
And that's okay. So just take the additional steps. Make an appointment with the surgeon or a collegeist and take those initial steps and you'll know and if the door closes and you're like, I know that's not what I'm supposed to do. I do not feel good about this.
Or I feel good about this, but I don't feel good about this person. I want to go with a different surgeon. Go step by step, step by step.